[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
today we have far but then I did it and
then I felt like the time pass and then
you did it that was like in a second
yeah I did that's fast
man seconds go forever for you holy [ __ ]
but the real time second was pretty fast
yeah it was super fast yeah yeah cuz I
even made the decision to respond with
Matt in Mira girl I guess no maybe I
don't know what happening more of these
free doses oh you know last week we went
to Boston
you know we debut danger boys all right
how this crazy
what the reception was his reception
it was mind-blowing Lee really well blew
my mind because like I didn't know I was
kind of scared because of our comedy its
mission today
mm-hm and especially loved college
students but how a sensitive Boston
University and um I was just like man
let's I don't know I don't know what's
gonna happen cuz a lot of our fans today
too are not JK films fans mmm-hmm
but they're like Jay King news fans so
they don't even know that we usually
forget stuff like that we do content
like that isn't that weird
that's so much time has passed no Jake
is rebranded it's so many new brandings
yeah so so I wasn't scared in that way I
was just like man what is this gonna be
so the uncertainty was just kind of like
[ __ ] but as soon as it started playing
just laughter after laughter after
laughter like was there shocking moments
of like there was a point for you like
oh we weren't really trying to do that
that'd be a joke but they laughed at it
anyway they lose their moments like that
ever know all of our jokes hit okay but
what shocked me was the things that I
was like this is gonna hit didn't hit
that hard and other funny stuff hit
harder right so oh do you think that
will help you in the next project I
don't know because I feel like we have
it's kind of like a stand-up thing or
anything you have to play to the crowd
right
so over the years when we used to tour
with our other thing with our others
whole set and and our video certain
points would be always hitting and
there'll be some jokes that are like on
or off depending on the crowd so that's
probably what we're gonna witness is
like we're gonna screen this go
throughout all the different cities and
then whatever is consistent we'll know
those are actual good hits mmm
we have mental notes because I didn't
depend it does depend on the crowd like
Joe saying and then there were things
that I didn't really think was that
funny I'm just like a couple reactions
or looks from like the the other person
in the scene that was really funny and
I'm like oh those are those things were
like on set when you don't like know if
you're funny you know
and you know we run a couple of takes
like both Steve and case Joe can we
bring it up a notch bring it up a notch
and then sometimes you're like oh should
you actually don't need that like you
know a lot of the funniest things in the
office is something funny yeah in
minutes just someone else's look dude
honestly that has been my most favorite
thing like about your guys's skits it's
always and it usually tends to be you
part but like it's always the most
subtle thing that you do that [ __ ]
kills me like especially um like the
Black Friday it's good like even before
that like there were certain looks or
like the one where you guys were like
Jerry with [ __ ] I forgot all these are
any budgetary yeah Jerry it was that one
man you were [ __ ] killing me cuz
there's so many like subtle movements
and like subtle like little mannerisms
that you're doing ass like playing the
mom I'm a scary woman huh did you tell
me like it freaked you out close to good
I've been a woman yeah I was like you
Bart's gone into someone else yeah it
was awesome great with their characters
yeah but the next one I think is in
Irvine it's usually fine in January
hopefully we can all go there but you
know we're all gonna see it this week
right oh yeah that's right they are at
the wrap party weird
I'll threader all the records Billy
where is it done
we weren't even supposed to screen it
actually oh really night wait like you
weren't allowed like no we were they
originally booked us to talk about stuff
they booked us to talk about Asian stuff
in business stuff yeah
Asian stuff for business stuff boring
ass [ __ ] did you counter them like I
know you want us to talk about Asian
stuff oh we have a very yeah all day man
Casey was editing project have you seen
it so that's the thing like he told me
he'd know he told me when he was done he
was like you watch it but then like I'd
be busy with some one thing or another
and like I never got around to see it
but then like to kind of justify as to
why I didn't see it I'm like well I'm
gonna share my my viewing experience
with everybody
you should I'm like oh I'll just I did
end up seeing up until a certain scene
when you first started doing all that
but when he first started editing his I
didn't even get to do okay final product
of it but I did see like the first half
yeah and and I was like oh this is gonna
be good yeah was there a favorite senior
character that you guys could kind of
pull out from that screening that you
saw really building that character they
were always like I feel like there was
so much going on that you know when
you're too excited it just goes by lame
and that's what happened to the friend
right cuz I wasn't able to step out I
was all because it was um I haven't
seemed to set it you know so it was my
first time too um so I was enjoying it
voilá was trying to take mental role and
all that was just like [ __ ] I really
like the Gina's character I think
because it's like she's playing a side
character she has to hit that one note
and she does is so good it's it like
right on the head yeah over and over
over and over so it's super super yeah
member her day when she was shooting
that was really how special I thought I
was like man it hurt over here he's
[ __ ] pulling it out yeah
so for those of you that don't know like
I guess to fill in people like what do
you plan on doing with this this project
so right now what we're doing is we're
touring again doing shows again and
whatever school is allowing us to screen
it we are screening in and doing q and
A's about it and then meanwhile on RN
were like pitching to studios or setting
up meetings I mean right now it's like
holiday season so there isn't yeah
there's not like the in-person stuff but
we do have people sending it out sending
like the teaser out so hopefully the
goal is to get the whole thing picked up
by a studio fund it will probably
reshoot the whole pilot but it's okay
because that was the goal that that's
our ticket in and then meanwhile when we
do all these shows we get people really
excited about this project so if you
guys work for school or organization and
you do want us to screen and go to book
jkf at gmail.com that's the only way
we're gonna show it to is live in person
yeah and follow the danger boys six to
six Instagram
you guys got to follow that cuz the goal
is to kind of create like a cult
following like that's the way you got to
do it these days is it though if you're
like a digital artist or like kind of a
nobody still write what you have to do
is build a cult following around what
you're doing and have a built-in
audience kind of like how Miranda sings
did with with her massive thing on
Netflix you know and all that so
hopefully with a Derek comedy and on
Glover
where he he had the mystery team and
then they never showed it it was just
like it was at Sundance and it was that
film festivals or a personal screenings
and things like that so you never
actually got to like you know yeah so
that's kind of where we're like tapping
into the community everybody getting
together and if we released it out of
nowhere yes it could build a following
but we can't get the rest funded yeah
the way that Netflix and all these other
guys work is like they want exclusive
exclusivity and technically I don't
think they think that it's that
exclusive if like a hundred people saw
it yeah so that's kind of like the route
we're taking that's the strategy what
about for you guys I know you guys like
first join JK tour like work on
narratives it's not like how did it feel
to finally be able to work on something
that's not really good yeah
that was the first big narrative project
that I've already done with you guys so
that to be involved with it especially
to be shooting it it's like I was like
holding a cameras like wow
doing it it was a really weird feeling
cuz I'm just like wow it's like
something different from like setting up
stuff like a party or news and stuff
like that so you feel like you're
training kicking back in you're like oh
my god definitely like oh my all the
stuff that I've done previously or other
stuff where I'm like I would just be
asking like all the crew is great on it
like I just asked for something I be
like hey I need this moved or what
everything like okay and they just
disappeared and when did it like I
didn't need to like you know go do it
myself I didn't need to like worry about
like oh I've got to do this and this and
this I could just focus on the thing
that I needed to do and then everybody
else is refreshing superfriend and it
was nice to know that like I guess the
crew dynamic still carries through
because I mean we've done a lot of party
shoots kind of together and like with
all you guys has cast and stuff but to
know that the dynamic still works
shooting a short really good yeah it was
like oh what good we can definitely
shoot a whole series of this could shoot
a whole season of this like yeah just
with the people that we have here with
maybe like a couple extra hands but like
that was super exciting for me to like
just work with everyone on some project
like that I know how happy she felt even
though it was very stressful to produce
everything she was just like this is and
so with B toys like they both worked on
it together to produce it and they were
like in their element they really were
shoutouts to production because there
was there are quite a few uh production
hiccups that were just sort of like you
know what we need to find when people
drop in our last second we had
last-minute on the day of that was the
roughest day I think for them I'm not
telling stuff man I felt really bad for
Brandon and Julia cuz I was like yo I
don't know how you gonna do that but
that's not my job so we can have to tell
them less cuz I've been really like
Randall your ran out on the on line it
was like and I was like can I do that
mid that we got into town they were
looking for it and they're like shut up
we're shooting you were like sorry we
got the talent to come later as weren't
a celebration
yeah those were at the cellar I don't
you guys been on other sets and stuff
but there's always drama or problems
that happen within the group a lot like
no some issues going on there like a
tyrant director or whatever and then
that's one thing I think is is really
important is that synergy and in our
group the worries that we have is always
outside and we're just
cool stuff like technical stuff yeah
like but inside it's fun the whole time
it's fun you know the best formula yeah
I'm like you guys come like Arman Arman
just like we got this like happening
from the outside no matter what
at least we're solid inside the first
day of shooting with the Mariachi like
coming in and screw up the sound like
that was crazy [ __ ] and they start a
second like after we were done second
they had a full-on Kinzie net setup shot
out like Julius Franz hostages the
scenes with like Steve and then like
when we're dead for a long time could
have said bring all the gear out of our
we had shot this office earlier yeah we
were like moving locations yeah like
packed in and pack back and then we did
all in then were with right when we got
there and we're ready to shoot all those
like trying to see that didn't require
sound nothing at all quiet as it was
like we don't need sound for this one so
whatever quiet and there was like I cold
now we're moving up sound oh oh Kylie
you ready I'm ready
well maybe if we wait and then we waited
like five minutes over like loud so we
waited and and we got lucky there were
sound test yeah they were so the party
was gonna go on later so we're like [ __ ]
the party's happening now and they were
like oh should it stop so we just went
and started recording yeah yeah and then
we finally moved to interiors and then
at that point it was like muffled enough
that were like okay we can live with
this like it's not perfect but with it
you actually you can't even tell us when
we screened it in like a theater with
big speakers I don't hear any like
traces of it at all how the cow is a
good mixer cause a good sound
I can't you came all together yeah cuz I
was I was nervous to shooting it because
I was like a lot of the scenes that cuz
I saw it like a rough the Casey showed
me like a really really rough rough when
I was it go no music yet there was like
a little bit but there wasn't like a
soundtrack soundtrack it was just like
kind of like but I could definitely tell
that needed more polish on it so I was
worried that like a lot of things that I
was shooting weren't gonna hit as jokes
and stuff because
shot out of order too so a lot of them
like context wasn't really there and I
was worried like I don't know how this
is gonna look but I kept on showing it
to case in cases like it's fine it's
finally okay and I saw about cop
together I was like oh this is funny it
works that's true cuz like since we
created this script and all that I can
see the bits and pieces happening and
then coming into coming into real life
but then for you guys when you get the
script and then but then you're filming
it and then it's doing it's all out of
order mm-hmm it's it is it's kind of
like how is this piecing together with
that yeah cuz I know you that on set you
guys are talking a lot about how the
characters are supposed to be
interacting and stuff it's like oh he's
supposed to be this character so you
should do it like that no just like I
don't the [ __ ] any of this means alright
I was like director says it's cool
director says it's cool and I kept
seeing Katie was so cute because he had
his empty back he's got these yet the
director stands where he was doing this
like he instead kept talking I was like
at lunch we should go grab Katie's back
I go hide in umbrella
that's crazy cuz really back in a day
when we used to hit skits like every
weekend right and I would see him always
with the backpack and his camera and I
thought that backpack was full of lenses
and all that because when we found out
it's a security blanket cuz he just
feels snug I'm like that's like a
straitjacket for him that's his like
little three copper yeah straightjacket
is not a cop it's a swaddle I didn't see
why soon yes in there no I think Danny
probably did but it was like what do you
have in here and it's just like so like
oh I hope he shows it to the screening
with it all but that's good times don't
man feels really good shoot yeah are you
is there any is there you're like a
dream school that you want to that you
want to show it at
someone that's not invited you but you
would love to have a dream studio we get
for me the school show me the most loved
and that's where we have the biggest
connection cuz I think college students
watch JK like that's the you know but
ultimately you know I would like to see
it on Netflix or something oh yeah like
that that that's the goal
but yeah cuz the goal is to have as many
eyes and joy and right right you know I
was just imagining like showing it like
my old school and stuff I was like
that's kind of that would be kind of a
neat idea to the place that I like
graduated from like look I didn't burn
out I did something
these [ __ ] do make me feel all
dope like I've been watch you since I
was 10 damn yeah that's a trip
it's been a long whoa I spin along right
though cuz now this is art it's gonna go
into our third year yeah so the fool
that says he was 10 is 23 now right now
imagine wants JK is legal to drink like
21 year old Jesus that's pretty nuts
how scary no in the years go by fad
especially what we're doing [ __ ]
crazy
the goal is though is like to transition
everything into that kind of stuff
yeah bigger project yeah whether we're
in it or we're writing and we get other
people in it and like yeah that's the
goal
yeah do you guys work on other projects
me personally yeah I get like I've been
getting so I've been slowly getting more
like assistant camera gigs so I've been
doing more of that recently it's been
really fun it's like definitely like
broadening my craft a little bit more
and practicing so this was a great it
was after danger boys too like I really
wasn't getting that much extra outside
work and then after I did that I don't
know if it was like a subconscious like
confidence boost or something like that
but I started getting a little bit more
like shooting some music videos and
stuff like that oh cool like I'm doing
this and doing that a little bit of this
a little bit that energy out there and
the
like yeah it's coming back so it feels
real nice to like I guess after the last
couple years I've been more focused just
on doing the shows that we've been doing
to branch out a little bit more into
extra stuff outside yeah real exciting
yeah direct kids like that but I have my
geeky youtube channel and in my writing
happening but that's really it
most of it is all like indie like an
individual you know it's not like I'm
like going out to like studios from like
that early editing finding books already
right uh a novella a short story okay so
in your contacts you think novellas
edition novellas just African dude lady
in distress well that's what it turned
into
first thing used to mean just like the
length of a book because there's a short
story novelette and then novella
which is just based on word count like
it's just how many words your is your
story so is it eight thousand or less
that's a short story
eight thousand I think seventeen
thousand is a double that seventeen
thousand to forty thousand is a novella
and then a novel is four thousand or
more so one of those and then I'm doing
a trilogy right now yeah so that's doing
I'm trying to go to comic-con next year
la comic line I finished my first comic
book so that happens cause like owning a
comic lines probably should have a comic
book because I'm at a comic convention
some have that as like a leader too like
my books though what does that mean like
to go like my own booth yeah my own
booth were you how much selling there I
think if you do like the standard one in
two thousand I'm gonna be an artist
alley which is less so I think smaller
booth it's a smaller one it's like a
place where just mostly where any people
go next like Hasbro or like yeah Dark
Horse a marble thing like I'm gonna be
like what the other indie artists yeah
that's good no it'll fit you with the
people that are looking for you right
exactly - yeah and I have a frame who
specifically says like everything he
goes to Artist Alley to find like you
know a new person that he is into
because otherwise you're just gonna be
another like little drop in the book and
X are you crazy company yeah yeah one of
the questions that we had from the
students was like oh how do you like
stay motivated like when you're working
on your passions and stuff like that and
we all of our answers were like do not
follow your passions do not build your
own business honestly you get to it so
much easier if you just do the college
route and yeah and just and get a job
job you know that's what we tell the
whole time
you're anti what they wanted here yeah
they want to hear some inspirational
[ __ ] and I'm all like no you're not
gonna get it from me because why is it
that you decide that route
I don't want competition I'm like I'm
not gonna inspire them and then one day
they beat me I'm just kidding but that's
the joke that's the joke but I think
it's a lot more than they think it's
gonna be I think I see a lot more I feel
like totally when I was at Apple it was
this I can just do the work yeah and
then clock out and then I'll maybe
remember do you remember that I sold you
a case at the Apple store at the Grove
it was like mm probably 11 whoa I know
she wouldn't remember I know I
remembered she's like but um what was it
oh yeah it was easy because you clock
out you know you just do your workout
and you really don't think about it at
all until you go back in yes I'm juicing
on it yeah it's always on your mind is
you have to it has to be it's always on
your mind and you're constantly
panicking yeah and it's self induced
panic when they asked me I'm like you
know my panic attacks like that don't do
this dude
yeah and but I think when we all gotten
into this we were imagining a world that
was so perfect right you're following
your dreams you're having a blast you're
doing all this [ __ ] and then you're like
life is great it is great right but but
it's not what you think it's gonna be
that's what I just want to say to the
students it's not what you think cuz
like like when you're working app or all
these other means like it's the same
thing it gets boring right and then you
want more of a purpose or you want
something else and it's like sometimes
the balance is okay mm-hmm but then when
you start wondering like what is it like
[ __ ] pursuing your dreams and
building a business just was a it's
stressful as [ __ ] yeah
but I still like it this way you just
know what what it's gonna be it's not
gonna be easier happier that's for sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]